in the event Communications go down how
does the military communicate they've
got contingencies I'm sure and they have
protocol for what happens if like the
communications go down but what about
local police federal law enforcement it
is there there's going to be a Decay a
breakdown as as uh as you get out
further and further side of the
government of actual Communications so
what happens then if the grid goes down
and Communications are blocked for some
reason we lose the internet we lose
electricity we're turning our radios on
trying to figure out what's going on
and then
bad people go on the radio and say this
is Lieutenant so-and-so I'm in charge of
this area and it's a random guy
then he comes in and says we're
organizing what if it's a militia and
they feel Justified and say to
themselves if we don't get a hold of
this it's going to get bad I'm taking
charge put out a radio call put on their
militia uniforms look like military show
up with guns they're not bad guys but
they're not the government and now
you've got conflicted factions
determining trying to figure out who's
in charge and who isn't